hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic I
remember it so you don't have to online
videos have come a long way haven't they
we've gone from the novelty of just
filming our cats to budgeted studios
that turn out professional work every
year as well as the novelty of just
filming our cats but there's a group of
entertainers that despite growing more
and more popular and having done this
for a year still meet with a lot of
hostility from Hollywood and those are
the entertainers who incorporate fair
use this is what we do now for those who
don't know fair use is the doctrine that
states excerpts of copyrighted material
may under certain circumstances be
quoted verbatim for purposes such as
criticism news reporting teaching and
research without the need for permission
from or payment to the copyright holder
so that means if you use copyright
material for a say a review or satire or
education it's completely legal
too bad Hollywood doesn't see the law
that way as for years video producers
have been battling off attack after
attack resulting in multiple deleted
videos sometimes even deleted channels
affecting the income of people who now
do this for a living in hindsight this
is no real big shock as Hollywood over
the years has repeated this pattern over
and over they just never realized
they're actually repeating it since the
early days there's always been something
that was going to destroy the innocent
artists who just want to do nothing but
give you movies first it was TV VHS
recording that it was DVR DVD rippers
and now right on cue
it's the Internet oh poor Hollywood look
at all the box-office records you're
breaking in the past ten years look at
all the new filmmakers that wouldn't
exist without online media look at all
the digital commercial tie-ins and
trailers that you're exploiting the hell
out of you're killing an Internet you're
strangling a like a newborn unicorn who
just wants to give you rainbows so
obviously like in the days of TV and so
forth internet did not kill or weaken
the Hollywood system but that didn't
stop them from trying to take control
anyway as we saw with acts like SOPA
giving complete control to US law
enforcement to combat online copyright
infringement with no due process
yeah that was a scary time for the
Internet Google even shut down their
site in protest and this isn't even that
long ago now thankfully that egg never
passed but that doesn't mean their
practices aren't still being put into
effect hi I'm Alex from I hate
everything three days after I released
my review of cool cat saves the kids a
terrible infamously bad movie
I received a suspicious copyright strike
from the director of the movie himself
Derek Savage who over the course of
about a month used this unfair strike to
censor and restrict my channel and even
tried to bully an apology at me and
private emails have since made public
this clueless man who has shown multiple
times that he has about as little
understanding of how the fair use law
works as he is knowledgeable in
competent filmmaking was given the tools
to waste my time and threaten my
livelihood purely because he didn't like
my negative review of his god-awful
movie which by the way I did actually
recommend at the very end of the video
you know so bad that it's good way and I
wasn't alone either it turns out mr.
Savage you've been on a copyright
striking rampage silencing at least two
other creators who had a negatively
slanted review of his movie savages
childish behavior aside this highlights
how hilariously slanted and weighted
against the Creator the YouTube
copyright strike system is he didn't
have to show any evidence he didn't have
to prove his case or worry about any
possible repercussions he definitely
would have lost in court if it had gone
there so once he failed to refute my
appeal the strikes time limit ran out
and my channel was eventually restored
to normal it was a colossal waste of
time and energy for everyone involved
hey guys it's YMS here to explain a few
things about YouTube's copyright system
it wasn't too long ago when one of my
videos was unjustly blocked worldwide
and I was unable to appeal it because I
had other appeals that had yet to be
resolved now unfortunately YouTube only
allows you to file three appeals at one
time what is the reasoning for this well
I'm not really sure but all it seems to
do is provide more leverage for the
claimant and less leverage for the
defendant there are tons of videos that
are taken down unfairly on YouTube
trying to put people who use fair use in
the same category as those who steal or
upload entire content for profit but how
can this be is there a system in place
in theory after Google bought YouTube
Viacom immediately went to court against
them for all the content being played
without their permission funny seeing
how Viacom actually uploaded about a
hundred the videos they tried to sue
YouTube over YouTube was able to defend
itself with the DMCA
safe harbor provisions they created a
system that was shed any responsibility
for any videos uploaded on YouTube and
again in theory helped protect its
creators this system was is and will
continue to be abused for some reason in
a much more rapid pace this past year
the system is there's two penalties for
copyright infringement a claim or a
strike a strike is the most severe your
video gets taken down from YouTube
because a copyright owner sent a
complete legal request asking YouTube to
do so just one strike limits your
channel including only airing 15-minute
videos and an inability to dispute
content claims for six months you get
three of these and your channel is gone
and then there's the more popular yet
less severe penalty claims if Content ID
detects copyrighted material within your
video then an automatic action will take
place this action is entirely dependent
on what the copyright holder previously
said it to do for example if I owned a
movie and I wanted to add it to
YouTube's Content ID system I would get
to decide how much footage from my film
would need to appear in someone else's
video before it automatically claims it
you can also receive claims that were
filed manually a manual claim implies
that somebody actually watched the video
and determined it was infringing before
filing the initial claim so how can that
possibly be unfair YouTube's system is
set up in such a way that incentivizes
claimants to abuse it and that is
precisely why their system is rampant
with abuse you can file a dispute and
then it's up to the claimant to respond
to your dispute within 30 days if they
don't respond within 30 days then their
claim will be removed and your video
will be back to normal if they do
respond they can either remove the claim
or reinstate the claim if they reinstate
the claim then you have to file an
appeal and they have yet another 30 days
to respond to that the most excruciating
part was the lack of human interaction
from anyone at YouTube the automated
emails and forums seemed designed in
such a way that no human working
YouTube will ever actually see it so it
makes you feel pretty helpless and
pretty worthless there was no one I
could contact to fix a very very simple
problem so the entire situation was
elongated and needlessly blown comically
out of proportion I see no reason why
there should be a limit on the amount of
Appeals I can send when there's no limit
on the amount of claims I can receive
and what's worse is that even if the
amount of appeals was increased I would
still only really be able to use two at
a time
reason being is that during the appeals
process the claimant has the option to
remove your video and issue a strike on
your account you can fight to get your
video back up and get the strike removed
from your channel by filing a counter
notification but those can take up to a
month to complete as well and as soon as
you have three strikes on your channel
at any one time your channel is
automatically removed so even though I'm
technically allowed three appeals at
once I make sure to limit myself to two
in case all of them come back with
takedown notices but okay so some
companies are gonna be unfair and some
even make mistakes at least they're
gonna try not to do it again right why
there are no penalties for companies
creating false claims or strikes in fact
there's a claim where you can take
someone's monetization on a video even
if the claim turns out to be false so if
a studio says hey your event horizon
review that's our review 100% they can
take the money you're supposed to be
making on it until you file a
counterclaim and if they never fight it
or a proven to be wrong they still get
to keep all the money that they made us
no questions asked but there's even more
they can do than that you would think
that Studios wouldn't go around filing
fraudulent claims against people's
videos but not only do they do that but
they often outsource other companies to
do it for them I've received countless
claims from a rights management company
known as a Guetta and this claimant in
particular is one of the worst to deal
with you can dispute your claim and
provide factual evidence as to why your
content falls under fair use and they
just reinstate their claim anyway and
will often issue a takedown notice
against your video so you might be
thinking well big deal so you had to
fight off a claim every once in a while
how often could they possibly happen a
few times a year maybe once or twice a
month
every other day we have to fight off a
new claim I fought and won every single
illegitimate claim thrown my way but as
the number of videos on my channel
increases so does the likelihood that
I'll be stuck with too many claims to
deal with it once there's countless
videos on my channel that I was unable
to monetize for several months just
because of how long the claims process
takes it's gotten to a point where we've
had to change our content dramatically
clips of films have been intensely
reduced down as some reviews don't even
use clips they use reenactments however
as other cases proved even not using
footage isn't enough
I received a strike on my account on one
of the midnight screenings reviews which
is a series I do in which me and another
person sit in a car in a parking lot
after going to see a movie in the
theater and we just talk about the movie
there's no clips no footage it is just a
sitting in a car talking about a movie
and if you didn't know that you could
know that by just simply watching the
video so what started out as a means to
protect Studios and content creators
it's now being used as a means to
silence and steal we're at a point now
where not only is this becoming more and
more wrong it's becoming illegal in the
case of lens versus Universal Universal
claimed a 29 second video of a baby
dancing to a prince song infringed
copyright yeah that's how desperate it's
getting thankfully EF f sued Universal
on lenses behalf arguing that Universal
abused the DMCA by improperly targeting
a lawful fair use a federal appeals
court affirmed that copyright holders
must consider whether a use of material
is fair use before sending a takedown
notice but don't worry that still didn't
stop the studios from wrongful DMCA
takedowns tons of them still going on
today studio ghibli gave us a strike for
telling people to go see my neighbor
totoro
ironic as the studio that created the
no-face creature who just wants to
spread joy but gets
zoomed by greed gobbling up anything
that comes in its way it's now sadly the
perfect mascot for this situation when
we upload an extended version of our
commercial reviews the Apple commercial
about the 1984 future got claimed the
comedy rights itself a company warning
us about an Orwellian future saying
they'll lead us away from a world that
controls and sensors us is controlling
and censoring us wow you really stopped
that future from happening the studio's
have made it clear they are not going to
play fair and they will step over
anybody's rights that they need to to
get exactly what they want so what needs
to change well first make it so that
studios can't steal money that's
rightfully yours if there's a
monetization claim why not place that
money made for the video in a side
account that way if the claimant
releases the claim the money should go
to the Creator
second the three-strike rule how come
one strike disables you from disputing
any other copyright claim if we were
going by baseball rules does one strike
limit the batter's ability in any way up
one strike that means you can always
swing half way two strikes that means
you can only swinging at balls on
certain sides of the plate fighting
claims is something that every channel
will have to go through at some point
help with these examples it's inevitable
and some of us go through it more often
than others so why take away your right
to fight that especially if it turns out
the party accusing you is wrong
in fact since a court ruled that fair
use has to be taken into consideration
why not a grace period before any action
is taken a strike should not
automatically and immediately be placed
on your account there should be time to
notify you too that you're fighting the
DMCA takedown and until that's resolved
and seeing who's right or wrong
and a cow shouldn't be penalized which
leads to the most important part
clayman's need repercussions for false
claims you can lose money or your
channel due to claims and takedowns
those are the penalties you have to
suffer so why isn't there any penalty
for ones that are retracted or false it
just allows one side to have all the
power there's a great irony that the
creation of Hollywood and these studios
from something similar to what we're
going through right now Thomas Edison
held many of the patents over the
technologies needed to create movies and
he was overly tough on upholding them
exhibiting in near monopoly so creators
fled to California and created Hollywood
because they thought the limitations and
abuse of control was getting out of hand
yeah sound familiar years later the
studio's now are the ones who are trying
to live it in control while the creators
are still trying to create it's clear
that this current system is made to be
abused it will continue to be abused
until a it's fixed or be the affected
Channel gets big enough to give the
claimants enough bad press to scare them
into not filing the claim and that
shouldn't be how things are done I've
been doing this professionally for over
eight years and I have never had a day
where I felt safe posting one of my
videos even though the lost days I
should be safe posting one of my videos
for years Hollywood has been wrong about
what will destroy them and every time I
suppose that threat came about when
trying to take them down didn't work
they inevitably turned to the most
obvious and logical solution join forces
Hollywood works with TV and Hollywood
should work with the Internet this is
proof that the only thing that can
destroy Hollywood is Hollywood the
system that is in place is being used by
studios and now even other content
creators as a scare tactic to silence
criticism and stunt channels that could
grow into popular media outlets but
aren't because they could say something
somebody doesn't like some businesses
have picked up on how to utilize this in
fact online creators have given
attention to movies shows and games that
probably would disappeared unless the
internet brought focus to it it doesn't
even matter if it's good or bad in fact
it's usually looked at more if it's
glorified for being bad this is the kind
of goldmine so much media is missing out
on some studios recognize the power of
the internet and go in the direction
they know media is going but others
still see the change is too hard or too
much work not willing to put in the
effort to do what they know is right
when you receive a claim it hasn't even
gone through a human being yet
YouTube gives claimants the power to
make money off of your video before it's
even been determined that your video is
actually infringing upon their copyright
once your content creators be
responsible for having to deal with
angry people who take reviews personally
and use that anger to maliciously target
and silenced voices with a system that
allows them to do so
it's no wonder Studios don't think twice
about issuing illegitimate claims
because chances are either you won't
fight back or you won't be able to fight
back and only months after this incident
my entire channel was taken down for
about 17 hours because of false spam
flagging it took multiple weeks to even
receive any kind of explanation or
apology from YouTube directly and if I
never made such a loud noise about it my
channel would have remained taken down
for no reason look piracy is a problem
and if someone is pirating your work or
even worth making a profit off of it you
have a right to stop it but not at the
cost of freedom of speech and fair use
is freedom of speech the funny thing is
it doesn't even take much to spot fair
use if a video is running your product
with you - no comments or changes or the
changes are just alteration so that they
don't get caught it's probably piracy
but if the video isn't even half the
length of your work and someone
constantly comes on to talk about it or
it's edited to make a point or use
satire then it's probably fair use and
sure some mistakes can come from this -
it's expected but not nearly as many as
the system that is in place now not at
the cost of common sense because here's
the thing we're not going away content
creators like us have only gotten bigger
and all your attempts to keep us down
have only made us stronger no matter
what you do we will always find a way to
comment - praise to criticize to
satirize and to educate and to all the
youtubers out there whether you make a
living at this or you just watch for
entertainment this is something we all
need to stick together because changes
already happen many studios whether
gladly or begrudgingly are being forced
to work with the Internet but there are
still some who
want to stay away and we'll do anything
in their power to stop online
entertainment from evolving including
infringing your rights we need to show
this isn't okay and it never will be
okay if we can make it clear now that
fair use is real it's being abused and
it's hurting the growth of an industry
you love to watch or produce we can
create a more stable environment for new
creators to produce great work the
Internet is a place where anyone can
become famous let's try to keep it that
way
I'm Alex from I hate everything and
where's the fair use I'm Adam from YMS
or your movie sucks and I've been asking
where's the fair use I'm the Nostalgia
Critic where's the fair use
hey everybody Doug Walker here doing the
charity shout out and this week
appropriately enough we are doing the
Electronic Frontier Foundation AFF this
is the leading civil liberties group
defending your rights in the digital
realm as you know technology is
transforming our society and empowering
us as speakers citizens creators and
consumers which unfortunately means a
lot of our freedoms are going to be
threatened the bigger I guess an e FF is
the first line of defense
they broke new ground WA was funded in
1990 well before the air net was on most
people's radar and continue to confront
cutting-edge issues defending free
speech privacy innovation and consumer
rights from the beginning they
championed the public interest in every
critical battle of affecting digital
rights see all the various ways freedom
of speech is trying to be threatened
what they're trying to do about it and
how you can help with all of us getting
together we can help keep the internet
fair and free
you